nous aimerions le faire moi c'est mon
rêve non mais je les doigts serrés ont
bien sûr mais à mon avis demandé leur
vous allez le faire maintenant je vais
pas leur demande à tout le monde moi je
ne mange rien n'est pas une star a une
chance c'est quoi ton qu'il met carreau
si j'espère qu'ils vont prendre ou non
mais non mais ça a été et a été un
moment donné l'année dernière il ya eu
des petites rumeurs mais bon ça faire et
couleurs lors la de l'avant testing
alors on va très bien qu'il vous ferez
ici danse avec les stars
moisson manhattan par la limite d'âge
moi je ferais bien mais là je perds un
os du schéma aussi si on est tous les
niveaux et tous jamais jamais jamais tu
prépares tu prêt mais moi non mais
personne n'aurait jamais elle ferait
évidemment mais moi je trouve que mon
avis on doit apprendre beaucoup de
valeur dans ce genre de compétition le
partage l'aide l'audace du sénat pour
les valeurs à 25 ans il passe comme un
lieu de 70 j'avais demandé non mais y a
juste proposé comme ça fout un biennois
ou quoi j'aurai deux couples ont demandé
de faire danser les stars jean luc j
avais rencontré martin je pense et des
premières rencontres
et voilà et je leur ai dit que j'allais
rentrer ralentir le groupe et ça
s'arrête là
non vraiment proposer ce plat chaud
[Applaudissements]
jolie va évidemment je me sens moule
[ __ ] le samedi soir puis je pensais en
costard le dire à ses paquebots non
c'est papy est proposé beaucoup de
règles propres et espère bien passé
reste elle denis qui présentait non
maître nageur de la piscine
non c'était pour faire là bonjour
[Applaudissements]